it never goes exactly how i think it's
going to but somehow it always ends up
being better
miley cyrus holds nothing back in her
january cover issue of rolling stone
magazine
candidly addressing hot topics like her
former marriage to liam hemsworth
drug abuse hannah montana and how the
media's focused on her sexuality
left her with some trauma people kind of
try to make you seem out of control and
actually i'm
a pretty happy centered person that that
likes to do a lot of
you know things for people and i'm you
know not driven by kind of
just my own self and wanting more and
more the 28 year old musician poses
topless on the cover rocking some fierce
jewelry and smoldering makeup
and inside the mag she bears even more
while talking about her split from her
one-time husband liam
there's not much to say other than you
know i always have like kept that
personal me and him and it's you know
it's something that's for him and i in
the year leading up to their december
2018 nuptials
miley says she and liam were playing
house
then the california wildfires completely
destroyed their malibu home
and left them with nothing which miley
says was the catalyst behind their
decision to marry
quote as you drown you reach for that
lifesaver
and you want to save yourself i think
that's really what
ultimately getting married was for me
one last attempt to save myself
the pair split less than a year after
tying the knot and miley expressed her
heartache through music
writing her emotional ballad slide away
after ending her marriage and having
vocal cord surgery miley says she made
the decision to quit
drugs and alcohol she tells the mag she
had just turned 26 at the time
and felt the need to get clean or risk
losing her life
quote i said i gotta pull my together
before i'm 27
because 27 is the time you cross over
that threshold into living or
dying a legend i didn't want to not make
it through being 27
i didn't want to join that club she's
referring to the number of artists who
died at 27 from drug abuse
including jimi hendrix janis joplin and
jim morrison
although miley admits she recently fell
off her sobriety and drank alcohol amid
the anxiety she felt from the
coronavirus pandemic
she insists she's been drug free for
years
at the time of the interview miley says
she's five weeks sober
quote i try to not be naive things
[ __ ] happen
but from sitting here with you right now
i would say it would have to be a cold
day in hell
for me to relapse on drugs
miley also keeps it real about hannah
montana of course the role that shot her
to superstardom as a teenager
she calls the role larger than life
larger than me
and admits it took some time for her to
accept it
quote hannah montana was not a character
it was about a normal girl with a
wig on everything was always in me the
concept of the show
it's me i've had to really come to terms
with that
as for miley's career as an artist she
says it's been full of struggles
too balancing her artistry with her
sexuality
[Music]
she explains when fans think about her
2013 hit wrecking ball they don't recall
the pain
or the tears in her eyes instead quote
you remember me getting
naked and i don't know whose fault that
is
it's something that's also frustrated
miley's mom tish
quote she was like what the [ __ ] you
have the biggest song can you just make
it about the song
why do you have to make it about being a
stripper she didn't change your mind
i've never been one to really care about
what people think because i'm the artist
you know what i mean
and that's the art that i'm doing and
doesn't really matter what everyone else
thinks as long as you're happy with you
know what you do
today miley feels so settled in who she
is and what she's doing as an artist
she also wants to help pave the way for
artists to come the way she says
debbie harry from blondie did for her
you